đã lấy phòng bình hàng tục tấn tás, tổng trám khẳng định,
Mỹ và Ngà đã bắt đầu thảo lợt về khả năng đặt được một thả tất mới,
nhằm thay thế hiệp ước cách giám và giới hạn bú khi tấn công chế lực,
New Start.
Ông Nhân Mạnh, đây là vấn đề mang tính toàn cầu,
tặc miệt khi hiệp ước New Start sọc hí thạn.
Tuyên bú mối nhất này, đánh dở buất khởi động cho các lỗ lực
tái lập khu đe khổ kiểm soát bu khia dân, giữa Mỹ và Ngà,
sau thời gian dài, bị gián đoạn bởi kết thẳng chính chi và xuống đột lệ ích.
Theo hiệp ước New Start,
mối bên chỉ được chình khai tối đa,
Mỹ trăm tên lửa đạn đạo xuyên lục điệp ICBM.
Tên lửa đạn đạo phống từ tông nâm SLBM và Mỹ bây nay bauh hạn năng.
Những ước này, được xem là dạo chắn quý cùng giữa 2 khó hủ khi lời nhất thế giới,
và sẽ hết giữa lực vào đầu năm hành in thông chăm 20 xấu.
Tuy nhiên, với việc các kênh lên là dự Mỹ và Ngà vẫn trong trạng thái mong mai,
đến trình đà phán sắp tới sẽ đối mặt với New Zowkan.
Cà về kí thuật lẫn chính chi, đe dưới chi sẽ tự chế lực,
đang bị thách thích mạnh mẽ, mời các nhân tố để chính chi mới.